non era una notte buia e tempestosa era
una giornata d'estate
lessi un'intervista a questa persona che
non so che con se conoscete si chiama
cornel west è un filosofo politologo
americano riconosciuto per essere tra
gli ideologi diciamo poi gli ispiratori
di occupy wall street di cui forse
avrete sentito gli fecero molte domande
soprattutto in tema di futuri presidenti
degli stati uniti perché era ancora pre
lezione del signor trump è una delle
ultime domande che gli posero era bene
tu sei stato protagonista di occupy wall
street ha eseguito tutta questa nascita
di questo movimento quale sarà la
prossima grande il prossimo grande la
grande prossima mobilitazione di persone
quale sarà la causa attorno a cui si
mobiliteranno le persone quale sarà la
prossima occupy wall street e lui disse
avrà certamente una caratteristica al
femminile il 21 gennaio 2017 circa un
milione di persone
sempre secondo i dati della questura
sono scese in piazza in tutto il mondo
in più di 800 600 800 location e avevano
un tratto comune queste manifestazioni
avevano tutte diciamo si ispiravano alla
grande marcia di washington che appunto
si è svolta poi il 21 il 21 di gennaio e
che aveva il tratto del un tratto
femminile è stata una cosiddetta women's
march nata anche per come dire sapete un
po i tratti ma cinti che ha assunto la
campagna delle presidenziali americane
una profezia che si è avverata
e come dire è confermata anche come dire
che la questione sia rilevante
confermata anche da profezie più
nostrane cet eurisko come tante altre
società che fanno ricerca statistica
socio demografiche di trend è venuta a
raccontarci qualche mese fa in action
aid quando ci muovevamo per iniziare a
tracciare le linee della nostra prossima
strategia di azione a raccontarci 10
trend rilevanti da tenere in
considerazione se vuoi guardare il
futuro tra questi dieci trend hanno
identificato la questione
dell'empowerment femminile come una
questione è incorsa in itinere non
risolta ma che sarà ancora più rileva
nei prossimi anni più rilevanti in
termini di cambiamenti socio demografici
occupazionali eccetera quindi come dire
una profezia che che dobbiamo tenere
presente che questa questione è
rilevante che la questione
dell'uguaglianza lo sia probabilmente
molto condiviso ci si divide un po se
sia solo questione di tempo o se e che
quindi sia un trend un po inarrestabile
una valanga che va per conto suo o se ci
siano delle azioni che possano
accelerarla è vero che solo una
questione di tempo pare è anche vero che
forse se il tempo peggiora
probabilmente la cosa diventa ancora più
rilevante questa è una è un disegno
stilizzato di una politica che forse
conoscete che ha theresa may e che
racconta una delle sindromi diciamo
socio sociali in tema di uguaglianza più
nuova conoscete tutti sicuramente la
sindrome del soffitto di cristallo la il
fenomeno la fenomenologia del soffitto
di cristallo che impedirebbe alle donne
di raggiungere certe posizioni di
leadership
questa è un'altra sindrome è quella
della scogliera di cristallo traducendo
dall'inglese che dice così hanno
identificato alcuni ricercatori che è
più facile che se un paese o un azienda
attraverso un momento di crisi o un
momento di forte transizione traumatica
è più probabile che a guida di quei
paesi o di quelle aziende venga posta
una donna cioè nelle posizioni che sono
più a rischio è più probabile in questo
lasso di tempo che arrivi una donna e n
analisi di perché questo avviene quindi
sicuramente è una questione di tempo
forse se il tempo peggiora diciamo sele
come dire le condizioni a contorno
peggiorano è più probabile che ci siano
delle accelerazioni in termini di
leadership al femminile
e allora perché occuparsene perchè c'è
ancora chi oggi lavora per la cosiddetta
uguaglianza di genere barra pari
opportunità io mi sono date tre risposte
che ovviamente sono tre risposte molto
personali
una è perché periodicamente quelli che
sembrano diritti acquisiti in tema di
pari opportunità di eguaglianza uomo
donna in momenti particolari della
storia vengono posti in discussione vi
ho messo qui sempre la figura del
presidente americano
il presidente degli stati uniti perché
come sapete uno dei primi atti con cui
ha voluto segnare all'inizio della sua
della sua entrata in carica è stata alla
fine l'interruzione di tutti i
finanziamenti alle organizzazioni non
governative che in giro per il mondo
lavoravano a tutela anche del diritto
d'aborto quindi diciamo chiaramente una
una mossa anche molto molto forte molto
simbolica no in termini in termini di
diciamo di posizioni ma ci sono
periodicamente in inglese di chiamami
backlash cioè il periodo in cui quello
che sembra acquisito in materia
soprattutto di pari opportunità e di
uguaglianza può essere messa in
discussione si può arretrare non è dato
per come dire per certo per sempre prima
ragione seconda ragione è qui prendo
disperazione da una una testimonianza di
un attivista che che sta lavorando da
molti anni nella prevenzione e contrasto
alla pratica delle mutilazioni genitali
femminili in africa in un video
intervista che stiamo tra l'altro con
consolidando in questi giorni dice ha
sicuramente scomparirà questa pratica è
solo questione di tempo
eppure c'è un motivo che mi fa lavorare
pur sapendo che è solo una questione di
tempo il motivo è perché io avrò finché
ci sarà come dire un'ultima bambina non
sarà consolante dirle a quest'ultima
bambina che ha subito quella pratica che
era solo una questione di tempo che lei
era l'ultima perché avrò una bambina
come dire che è l'ultima e questo a
questa questione come dire mi fa
accelerare mi fa dire che non posso
semplicemente aspettare che la cosa
scorre succeda
e poi c'è una questione molto personale
che mi è entrata un po più nella testa
da quando da quando sono diventata mamma
non lo so se avete mai pensato che noi
rispetto a chi è chiaramente come me non
ha vissuto la seconda guerra mondiale si
è trovato a fare delle domande ai propri
nonni tu in quel momento da che parte
sta di tutto chi eri da che parte sta vi
è in questi e in questi anni mi sono
fatta questa domanda rispetto alle morti
nel mediterraneo e mi sono chiesta se
tra 20 anni mio figlio mi chiederà da
che parte ero rispetto a questa a questo
fenomeno e magari mi chiederà in questi
ultimi 30 anni in cui dovremo
preoccuparci di eguaglianza uomo donna
da che parte ero cosa stavo facendo
vorrei potergli rispondere che ho fatto
una cosa sarà molto molto piccola ma ma
mi chiederà sicuramente qualcosa e poi
ci sono moniti un po in giro per il
mondo che potrebbe anche non accadere
che l'uguaglianza non è un destino in
qualunque circostanza
pensate che oggi da una ricerca diciamo
non statistica ma insomma in svizzera
solo il 5 per cento di posti nei board
diciamo nè gli executive nelle stanze
del potere delle società finanziarie
occupato da donne
in giappone il 2 però l'italia va già
meglio c'è il settore finanziario come
tanti altri settori
e ancora un settore fortemente come dire
precluso perenne dinamiche alle donne ma
ce ne sono anche altri siamo andati
molto in là come dire quando si inizia a
parlare di questi temi e spesso spesso
si va sul macro spesso si va sulle
grandi tendenze ma c'è una cosa che la
pratica femminista ti ricorda che a un
certo punto devi ripartire da te per
essere vera per fare un discorso che
abbia un senso una credibilità c'è un
momento in cui non puoi non puoi
escludere di ripartire da te da chi sei
dalla tua storia anche perché questa è
una frase che a me piace molto molto
spesso all'altro non ha bisogno di noi
se non intanto in quanto vogliamo
condividere un processo di miglioramento
di cambiamento e di liberazione non
potremmo chiamarlo così quindi qual è
quella esigenza veramente che ci muove
che ci fa stare dove pensiamo che abbia
senso e quindi riparto dalla mia storia
e di come sono arrivata a fondare una
piccolissima start up era esattamente un
po di anni fa 2009 c'era il g8 che c'è
ancora è in questi giorni combinazione
oggi domani e taormina è diventato il g7
ma non è che cambia molto la mia
organizzazione pubblica una piccola
ricerca che cercava di mettere in luce
come qualunque questione il g8 stesse
toccando della grande agenda
internazionale da la sicurezza alla
macroeconomia avesse una dimensione di
genere
avete a che fare con la questione
dell'uguaglianza potesse essere
affrontata dal punto di vista
dell'uguaglianza tra le varie
ricercatrici che fecero a parte di
questo piccolo lavoro di di ricerca c'è
una persona con cui poi sono stata
contattata sono state contattate da una
casa editrice che si chiama un'altra
economia che ha una casa editrice
indipendente di milano e ci chiesero di
riprodurre come dire questo esercizio in
maniera come dire un po più editoriale
più per il grande pubblico e lavorano a
questo a questo piccolo libro che si
chiama le donne reggono il mondo e che è
uscito sembra 2009 2010 e da qui è
partito un piccolo viaggio in giro per
l'italia perché ci hanno chiamate a me e
alla co autrice che sia mylène assiste a
presentarlo ed è a seguito di questo
viaggio che una sera ci siamo detti boe
stata un'avventura bellissima cosa
facciamo nella prima risposta è stata
facciamo un altro libro ma sentivamo che
era la risposta sbagliata e abbiamo
riflettuto molto se quello che avevamo
provato a dire a rilevare ad ascoltare
da questi incontri in tema di economia
donne cosa c'entra
l'uguaglianza rispetto ai grandi macro
tende economici occupazione
disoccupazione lavoro di cura potesse
diventare come dire un impresa potesse
diventare non solo un commento non sono
un analisi ma potesse diventare una base
su cui misurarsi e abbiamo fondato dopo
un po di pensieri questa agenzia di
viaggi culturale specializzata in viaggi
in italia quindi per chi vuole scoprire
l'italia e si chiama è lesta travel ora
riflettendoci a pochissime cose vi posso
vi posso portare di questa piccola e
giovanissima esperienza che a tre anni
sicuramente il tratto forse quello per
cui per cui mi hanno portato mi hanno
invitata a portare questa esperienza è
che non tutto quello che innovazione e
tecnologia e credo che sicuramente
ricorra molto in questa in questo
periodo storico
il fatto che l'innovazione abbiano la
base tecnologica però mi è piaciuto
molto il tar precedente no che ragionava
proprio sul fatto che che la biologia ci
dica ci dica altre cose
e forse le facoltà umanistica il testone
umanistico ce ne dicono ancora altre e
possiamo ripensarle in termini
innovativi e sicuramente non è una start
up tecnologica quindi una start up che
si basa diciamo sul sul patrimonio
storico artistico dell'italia e prova a
trovare delle modalità per riproporlo in
una maniera differente e non ho diciamo
come dire la nostra impresa è stata al
femminile la terza socia che ha fondato
con noi è una donna le persone che per
ora hanno collaborato con noi sono tutte
donne e probabilmente abbiamo vissuto
anche delle delle difficoltà o dei trend
delle dinamiche che vengono dal fatto
che che eravamo donne è sicuramente la
nostra storia personale che si è come
sempre intersecata rispetto alla storia
dell'impresa in questa storia ha contato
essere donne poi chiaramente è
un'avventura imprenditoriale dove la
dimensione di genere non è l'unica
io quello che ho trovato interessante
per me è quello di mantenere come dire
questo sguardo io tuttora lavoro per
questa organizzazione internazionale e
nel pochissimo tempo contribuisco un
pochino con qualche idea anche anche
alla società e che sono sempre di più le
convergenze tra pubblico privato profit
e non profit sia in termini diciamo di
di pensare l'innovazione di portare
innovazione tra i settori sia in termini
proprio di vera e propria collaborazione
pensate a tutto il ragionamento che il
terzo settore sta cercando di fare in
termini di aumento dell'impatto del suo
lavoro partendo da un approccio che
molto spesso era un approccio più di
tipo caritatevole assistenziale che oggi
non basta più non giustifica più il
lavoro
pensate a viceversa tutto il lavoro che
l'impresa il mondo del privato sta
facendo in termini di responsabilità
sociale quindi la dimostrazione che
l'impresa ha un valore sociale e come
questo valore sociale nei territori e
verso gli stakeholders e shareholders
che la compongono
quindi tante di queste dinamiche che
vengano dal profit da non profit e poi
pensate a tutto il discorso sulla social
innovation che effettivamente molto come
dire permea i settori e quindi l'idea di
profit non profit oh pubblico privato mi
sembra mi appare almeno dal mio
osservatorio più
come dire più fluido ecco rispetto alle
distinzioni di un tempo torna sul
discorso impresa donne impresa
uguaglianza denaro pil e uguaglianza con
due elementi perché come dire non mi
basta la dimensione economica quando
ragiono in termini di uguaglianza video
due esempi uno è un dato che forse
conoscete il ruanda il quinto paese che
dal punto di vista stando a degli
standard soliti di classifiche varie
internazionali è il quinto paese in
termini buono c'è nella classifica alta
in termini di uguaglianza ora immagino
che se avessi chiesto il quinto paese
per per il prodotto interno lordo
ricchezza non mi appresto eccitato
ruanda cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
moltissimi paesi hanno dei tassi di
uguaglianza di genere di pari
opportunità di uguaglianza uomo donna
che prescindono dal livello di sviluppo
questo è un dato che ormai è molto
riconosciuto
altro elemento invece andiamo su una
dimensione un altro esempio
completamente diverso ma che a me
restituisce proprio questo questo
aspetto una recentissima ricerca fatali
condotta a livello europeo ha dimostrato
che aumenta il rischio per le donne di
subire una forma di violenza
quando arrivano a guadagnare più del
proprio partner mentre si riduce
fintanto che da guadagnare meno arrivano
a guadagnare pari quindi questo dato ci
restituisce a mio avviso il fatto che il
tema della come dire delle risorse
economiche della power niente economico
è un tema cruciale fondamentale tema
delle risorse ma non ci dice tutto non
ci dice tutto su quali sono le
determinanti che portano paesi comunità
e famiglie a a ripensare il concetto di
uguaglianza
questa è un libro bello che forse
conoscete che è uscito di recente è
anche molto bello nel layout molto e
molto carino per come pensato con con
dei disegni che che che che io vi voglio
portare come esempio possibilità di
piccola rivoluzione sul comodino o se
secondo me sarà eletto
ai bambini maschi innanzitutto e non
solo alle alle bambine femmine che
ovviamente c'è un tema no di
riconoscimento di modelli positivi per
le donne per le ragazze per le bambine
di oggi ma c'è un tema di riconoscimento
di queste di questo cambiamento
possibile
tra i bambini tra i massi questa
rivoluzione si fa se questo libro per me
viene eletto ai bambini ai ragazzi
altro tema che che si legga questo è che
in questo momento la mia prospettiva
rispetto a qualunque attività di impresa
una qualunque attività diciamo di
d'ingaggio no di passione di
investimento civico deve aver presente
qualcuno che tra vent'anni
come dire vivrà potrà vivere un mondo
diverso
questo è un bellissimo lavoro che ha
fatto lui e ne spieghi che l'agenzia
sulla popolazione delle nazioni unite
che quest'anno per dire i temi cruciali
di cui bisogna occuparsi a livello di
sviluppo ha usato a storie e statistiche
basate sulle bambine che oggi nel mondo
hanno dieci anni e ha proiettato tutta
la sua narrativa sulle bambine quindi
femmine con con questa con queste icone
e con queste vite dietro ed è un
risultato secondo me dal punto di vista
dell'identificazione delle problematiche
molto molto interessante ultimo aspetto
si dice no dietro ogni grande uomo c'è
sempre una grande donna ma dietro ogni
donna soprattutto donne che fanno un
lavoro vogliono intraprendere questioni
di impresa o fanno un lavoro che le
impegna molto c'è un enorme lunghissima
e sempre più lunga catena della cura c'è
dietro ogni uomo
ma forse diciamo la donna si rende prima
conto di quanto di quanto quanta catena
della cura c'è dietro
e c'è un bellissimo articolo uscito ieri
o l'altro ieri su avvenire in tema di
ripensare il nostro lavoro più
equilibrato tra lavoro retribuito e
pagato e lavoro di cura andatelo a
leggere molto bello e di una docente che
fa una proposta anche faccio politica
molto interessante
ogni desiderio di libertà e ogni
desiderio di emancipazione
in questo momento per la fase storica in
cui siamo è possibile perché secondo
un altro che si cura delle nostre
famiglie della nostra casa e e mettere
assieme queste due dimensioni è
fondamentale grazie
[Applauso]